that unlike other general formulations
of evolution and pathogen evolution we
have some population of susceptible
individuals this blue individual is an
infected individual we look at how the
number of affected individuals with blue
spread but in order for evolution to
occur there's also diversity so maybe
that's another type of individual type
of infection red and that's also
spreading in the population so at this
level we could just study different
strains of pathogens and how they evolve
but typically infections are not do not
comprise of a single pathogen particle
so a lot of the time it's important to
consider what's going on within each
choice because within each host there is
a distribution of different pathogens so
for example this host is not entirely
infected with blue pathogen it's a
mixture of both and I'll look at this
perspective of within her 7 through 3
sort of problems the first one is on
influenza and how within her established
influenza might tell us something about
how it's some population level evolution
occurs second one is HIV where do you
with inverse dynamics are very important
because HIV infections are very long
they're their life long and just
understanding what happens within the
host is itself important and finally I'm
going to talk about a general two level
selection model so you can see this that
could be selection within hearse and
they could also be selection at the
between hearse level and that's not
specific to any particular pathogen
you'll see that in each of these
examples I use very different modeling
techniques there are different levels of
tractability and different levels of
rigor so let's start with influenza and
this is what would Katia Cole who's in
the audience and also Jonathan Mattingly
and Mike Reid and what I mean by the
antigenic drift of influenza is just the
pathogen of phenotypic change of
influenza from season to season so the
reason why you need to get a seasonal
influenza vaccine is because influenza
as the virus is changing over time and
as early as the 1950s and repeated more
recently experimentalists have tried to
on this
and this antigenic change of influences
by doing experiments on mice so these
are called passes experiments so they
take a influenza strain that's been
adapted to mice in this case it's PRA
and they take a naive mouse and mouth
has never been infected with influenza
and they challenge it with it after the
virus the infection has taken its course
they um sacrifice the mouse and then
take sample and challenge a second Mouse
with it
and they do this for ten to twenty
passages and they find that with naive
mice the string isn't phenotypically
difficut different olanta genetically
different from the original strain but
when they do this just slightly
differently
when they first vaccinate the mouse and
then two weeks later they challenge the
mouse and they do the same thing they
after the mouse has been in fact did
they sacrifice a mouse they vaccinate
the next Mouse against the same the same
thing they're going to infect the mouse
with and they do this many times they
find that they do get and antigenically
different strings at the end of these
passage experiments so you may say that
while this makes intuitive sense and
vaccinated mice they're immune their
environment the environment for the
pathogen has much stronger selection for
change
so therefore you'd expect this different
strain to arise and this is called
immune escape because the strain is
escaping community but selection needs
to act on a population and if a mouse
has been infected sorry vaccinated Mouse
is probably not going to have a very
large population of infections the
second time it's challenged so there's
something to be looked at here why is it
that you still get selection for these
antigenic these different types in
vaccinated mice which may not actually
have a very large infection so this
empirical evidence we have from these
passage experiments where we know that
from an initial infection after mutation
replication some mechanism allows naive
mice to rarely generate antigenically
different influenza types and vaccinated
-2 to generate different antigen
extremes and we also know from various
studies the time course of influenza
infection you can see they vary quite a
bit
but it's on the order of a week and
there's a peak unfortunately there's no
data that I know of where they take a
vaccinated individual and then measure
its time course after a second challenge
which would be helpful but I can
understand why those experiments haven't
been done so based on these two
observations we can put together a very
simple ODU model of infection and this
ODU model existed previously in the
literature it's a viral dynamics model
there are two variables C + VC is for
target cell you can think of this this
as the resource or in terms of
Jonathan's talk just before they they're
like the susceptible cells to the virus
the subscript R on the V means resident
so we're going to think of V sub R as
the infecting influenza virus the
resident virus these two terms represent
virus infecting cells this minus Delta
sub V sub R is just the rate at which
viruses are depleted the Delta sub R
represents both the natural death rate
of virus in a Hurst
it also represents the immune response
so if you think back to the passage
experiments mice which are naive will
have low Delta off the Delta R that just
corresponds to the natural decay of
virus in the body and maybe the innate
immune response and mice that had
previously being vaccinated would have a
high Delta R so that's just the
deterministic viral dynamics and because
we're interested in how antigenically
new mutant can arise I'm going to make
the assumption that mutations
antigenically beneficial mutations occur
at rate new times the population size of
the resident virus population and just
to informally tell you what happens when
a mutation does occur in the resident
virus population the dynamics are going
to change by introducing a V sub n the
mutant virus population which is also
going to infect the same resource pool
and also changes through a differential
equation so much of the resident virus
population but this Delta sub M is going
to be lower because presumably the
mutant virus is going to have
we're all going to have the horse is not
going to have a strong immune response
to the mutant virus and just to give you
an idea of what these dynamics look like
this is an infection of a naive Hurst so
the black solid line is the target cells
the blue line is always the resident
viral load yeah resident viral
population and the colored dashed lines
are the other color lines sorry other
mutants
so in this naive individual this is the
time course of the infection actually
this has many analogies with what
Jonathan just spoke about which is
because of this initial resident virus
does it sort of uses up all the
susceptible cells and so any mutants
that do occur don't really establish
themselves and in the vaccinate
individual there is a initial very small
virus population of the resident and so
if a mutation does occur but it's less
likely to occur it's going to have much
more resources to establish itself and
this is just in one simulation we like
to be able to say something in general
about this and it turns out it's not so
difficult with these sets of equations
you can calculate the probability of a
successful mutation successful meaning
this Poisson process occurs and the
mutant doesn't die out do just
demographics demographics and ethnicity
and that's just over the period of
infection the rate at which mutations
occur multiplied by the probability that
they don't die out in this case if we
assume that initially this mutant
population grows like a branching
process we can approximate the
probability of dying out as well we can
approximate the process of the branching
process and then we can calculate the
probability of extinction of the
branching process and it just so happens
that with these sets of equations it's
not it's possible to actually calculate
this integral
and so from that we get the probability
of a successful mutation which is the
probability and immune escape because
but we're also going to assume that
escaped mutant is not going to
successfully transmitted unless it
actually has a fairly large viral load
so the other calculation we need to make
is what is the area under the curve of a
typical mutant strain and that can also
be calculated from the equations but
with some approximation and what you get
overall is as a function of how strong
the immune response is to the initial
infection the resin enviros the
likelihood that an to immune escaper
antigenically different influenza type
is going to be passed on and the general
schematic of this relationship is as
there is increasing immunity to the
resident strain the probability of
immune escape the first increases and
then decreases that's just the
combination of the probability of
successful mutation and the area under
the curve given that a successful
mutation has occurred so what this tells
us is that possibly immune hosts drive
influenza in evolution and incomplete
immunity is what allows immune escape to
occur in this model and going back to
the passage experiments when we saw that
the mice that were vaccinated were the
ones that were most likely to produce
variants that were antigenically
different they weren't actually here in
this model it would be predicted that
they were here fully immune individuals
would not be expected to pass on a
antigenically different influenza type
so this is a result for within each host
if we want to take this to the
population level we could take this idea
and see what happens
so take the idea that partially immune
partial immunity is what drives
antigenic change this is actually
analogous to antibiotic antibiotic
resistance which is if you don't fully
take care of a bacteria with an
antibiotic that's when you're most
likely to form of resistance to develop
so if we look at the population level
and the antigenic pattern temporal
patterns of influenza on the left you
see this data which is the cluster
persistence of influenza strains this is
sort of like yesterday and my armories
took the the time that a bird species
exists like this is the time that a
particular influenza strain exists
before leaving the population and you
can see it's not exponentially
distributed it's not a memoryless
process it's sort of Markovian process
and the previous result gives us a
consistent explanation for why we don't
have this exponential distribution which
is in order for a new influenza type to
occur you need an you know you need a
large chance that well you need a
logical proportion of the population to
already be slightly immune and so you
first need you can't just have if your
population is completely naive then you
have to wait until some of them have
been infected and recovered and
partially immune to it before you start
seeing a new type so on the right you
have a graph of just a simple model
which incorporates this idea and the
qualitative pattern of it not being an
exponentially distributed distribution
is the main point I want to make with
that interestingly another prediction
that this result makes is um if
influenza vaccine is distributed very
widely and is not very good then what
you end up with is before the influenza
season starts and a lot of people are
already partially immune and maybe not
that yeah partially immune but not fully
immune in which case you may actually
see that it closer to an exponential
distribution of cost attacks okay so
that's the model for with in host
evolution of influenza and it's how it
can be used to sort of understand what
happens at the population level it's
early II model with a poisson
distribution poisson process for
mutation rates and i'm gonna move into
something very different which is um HIV
HIV is a chronic infection and a lot of
the simplifying assumptions I made for
influenza no longer apply so just so you
no in the last decade Oh sir the AIDS
related deaths from HIV have gone down a
lot and that's mainly due to
antiretroviral therapy it's as long as
someone has access to it and they take
it for the remainder of their life they
can live a fairly normal life
unfortunately antiretroviral therapy you
do have to take it for the entire life
there is a chance of drug resistance and
there are side effects so one of the
approaches to combating HIV treating it
curing it is to develop an antibody
based vaccine and the motivation for
this ulcer I should mention this is done
with Allen parel Stein at Los Alamos
National Lab and this is some
preliminary work but it's so interesting
I wanted to talk to you about it the
reason why they're aiming for an
antibody based vaccine is they're all
these antibodies that have been
discovered they're listed here that have
been found to be broadly neutralizing
against HIV so what I mean by that is
HIV is a highly diverse virus so you
can't have a vaccine unless it generates
an immune response that can tackle all
that diversity and these antibodies have
been found in patients and tested in the
lab they do neutralize a lot of
different HIV strains they don't seem to
help the individuals they're found in
but if you give these antibodies into
non-human primates who are infected with
HIV or you know you've exposed them
before give it to them before they're
infected with HIV it does seem to have a
positive impact
Yallah can decrease the viral load of
HIV by a lot I can decrease the
probability of transmission but the
difficulty in understanding these
antibodies and don't want to convey to
you here is that they're very small
these are ribbon diagrams I don't even
know how to make sense of them and it's
not even clear how they bind to the HIV
so this is that flat pod is the cell
yeah it's not the cell membrane it's the
membrane of HIV and this is the calm
protein
and so what researchers are trying to do
is develop a vaccine protocol that will
mimic the evolutionary processes that
occurred in a patient that produced
these antibodies in order to elicit
these antibodies and everyone and this
is very hard because broadly
neutralising and HIV antibodies have
been found to be highly mutated so in
this figure on the Left I'm showing you
for pandemic h1n1 antibodies and for HIV
broadly neutralising antibodies that's
what being absence for the number of
mutations they have on their variable
heavy chain gene and this is calculated
by sequencing the antibody finding the
closest reference heavy variable gene
that there isn't counting the number of
nucleotides mutations from it so it's
not an exact science but this is enough
to give you the broad idea which is
against pandemic influenza we see you
know 20 nucleotide mutations on the
heavy chain variable region but on the
broadly neutralising antibodies we see
much more you know 90 something it sais
that and so this it's unclear whether
all these mutations are necessary but it
seems that you know these broadly
neutralising HIV antibodies are strange
in some way and if it really were the
case that these mutations are necessary
well how are you going to generate a
vaccine that's going to elicit all these
mutations especially when you know
vaccines are supposed to work in a
relatively short period of time much
shorter than a course of HIV infection
so on the right here it's a further com
to sort of show you that maybe all these
mutations are not necessary I've taken
the data from this chavvy study in
patient cha V 505 so these are all
antibodies from one patient and from one
lineage that led to a successful broadly
neutralizing antibody these are three
time points and the use of each of these
dots is a different antibody and the
high is just a number of mutations so
you can see that the longer the antibody
has been the the later infection the
antibody
sample the more mutations it has and
this is consistent with immunologists
idea that during a chronic infection
antibodies are constantly undergoing
mutation and selection to counter the
HIV the pathogen but if that's the case
then how do we know that these HIV
broadly neutralizing antibodies are
highly mutated because those mutations
are necessary buses they may have been
the product byproduct of her lung
infections I should also mention that
along with being unusual these broadly
neutralizing antibodies are usually
found many years into chronic infection
so a very toy model but is already quite
complicated of what we might try to do
here is have a virus population and an
antibody population let's focus on the
first the top part of this graph and
their birth evolving because both the
virus is changing to avoid the antibody
response and the antibody is changing to
try to catch the virus and this is we
need some sense of what it means for an
antibody to be broad so for at least two
of the antibodies I showed you on the
first figure with the ribbon diagrams
they bind to functionally conserved
regions of the HIV so we're going to
assume that viruses have a conserved
region and a variable region and what
are these regions they're just strings
of digits which I have represented as
colored boxes so there are eight boxes
for each region a epitope and each color
represents a different say chemical
species so it's best not to think of
these vit strings as um like the amino
acid sequence or the DNA RNA sequence
think of them as a representation of the
properties that are important for
binding in these objects and binding
between antibody and viruses which is
what has to happen for an antibody to be
effective is going to be represented by
taking this antibody the string running
it along either the variable or the
conserved region and finding the longest
common substring so with this antibody
we're going to say it has a match length
of five with the variable
to conserve reject so these are the
units for anybody's a virus virus have
variable in conserve regions
antibody just is one and this is going
to be a continuous-time markov chain on
these different objects and there's
going to be selection where an antibody
that binds more virus has a higher
reproductive rate mutation which are
just flips of each bit and also
selection of viruses where viruses that
escaped or are not bound by as many
antibodies have a higher reproductive
rate yes
servoz is whether it matches and the
length of the match might be the degree
to which it binds yes as far as we know
I'm using dead fishes terminology this
smells like the biology but we don't
know what the biology smells like that's
that's the problem the field of
immunology has now gotten to a point
where we quite understand exactly what
the fitness or the selection forces are
but to a first approximation that seems
reasonable so this is um simulation
based stochastic continuous time Markov
chain all right so here are some
assumptions where you're going to make
on this model so what I said that
antibodies bind the virus the strength
of binding is going to be different
depending on whether it's finding the
variable the cold a conserved region and
this is empirically motivated this tells
you as a fraction of the epitope match
so that's the regions I showed you what
the matched school which you can think
of as the Fitness is going to be so
there's a threshold of 1/2 at least half
the epitopes have to match before
there's any fitness and with the
variable region it's linear with the
conserved region it's just a little bit
less than the variable region but it
still gets one at the same point and the
idea behind that is that these conserved
regions tend to be what's the word
hysterically hindered sir
they're on the virus they're sort of
blocked by very for various reasons so
they're less accessible and what that
means is in this model that the fraction
of the very epitome matched by an
antibody has to be higher for the same
fits in a conserved region versus a
variable region yes
right so I made them so close together
because I want to see well if it's just
a little bit less accessible how
different is it going to be how
difficult is it going to be together
antibody against everything and here are
some other just properties of the the
this model the shape space model I
picked so here this is four different
string lengths I've used length eight
but this is just to show you what
happens when we use like six so like 12
what is the distribution of antibody
binding ability so this shows you the
fraction of the virus has matched by any
particular antibody so here what I take
a subset randomly selected set of the
antibodies of that string length and I
have a reference panel of viruses
variable epitopes and then I see what
fraction do does each antibody what
fraction of the virus reference set does
each antibody binding and the idea here
is that there's always a variety of
antibodies it's not like every antibody
binds n viruses above threshold there's
variation there there's also the
variation in the mutational effect of a
on a virus so here I'm showing if I take
an antibody in a virus that match at
length 4 and I mutate the virus in one
position what is the impact and the
change in map match length you'll see
most of them use mutations of duality
rias they decrease the match length deal
with serious antibody and some of them
increase in mesh like yeah so the string
length you you actually literally mean
the string length or do you mean like
the amount that matches the string the
total string so so these so you
mutations that extend and decrease the
length I know what mutations so extreme
lengths of fixed and mutations just
change elements of the string the
binding length this changes for every
pair does that answer your question so
it is the master no this is Lake Bates
string and I'm saying what fraction of
viruses are bound by an antibody where
the match length is greater than a
threshold or fall so the match length
threshold is fixed at full and then I
vary the string length and I look at the
distribution of antibodies and their
ability to bind viruses I can tell you
more about it after okay and finally um
this is also a property we observe which
is even though there are many antibodies
in our immune system and the theoretical
diversity is high you don't need to take
all the antibodies in order to bind all
the possible there's redundancy in other
words you don't need all the end every
single type of antibody to fight all the
possible shapes there are and this is
just showing you as you increase some
randomly chosen subset of antibodies the
fraction of the variable epitopes you
expect about so these are just
properties that seem reasonable given
what we do know about the immune system
so now let me just show you the dynamics
and focus on this first panel yeah
x-axis is time this panel is the virus
population this panel is the antibody
population each line is a different
string and the colored from red to
yellow for the virus and blue to green
for the antibody just so you have some
way of differentiating different strings
the final panel is for both virus and
antibody their fitness levels because
every line here is a string but you
don't actually know whether these two
strings basically have the same fitness
like their different strings but maybe
they match the same fancy bodies so I
plotted the fitness to show you that
whether they overlap or not so the first
panel is a typical infection with a
single virus so I fixed the virus
population size that's 10,000 and the
antibody population size is 1000 we have
many more viruses and antibodies but I
constantly
that number sir the hope is that this
might give us some information of what's
actually happening and so you have this
infecting virus these antibodies have
after some period that's affinity
maturation which is the process by which
the antibodies learn the shape of the
virus and then after that there's just
noise there's too many different viruses
that escape these antibodies that
respond to it and it just looks like
possibly you can see here the fitness of
the infecting virus strain is high first
and decreases when these antibodies
emerge and then fitness of the virus
goes back up to one and the Fitness
antibodies go back to zero the second
panel happens less frequently affect
quite rarely which is after this initial
antibody response to that infecting
virus these purple lines appear and
purple is color color coded for the
antibody matching the conserved region I
should have mentioned the conserved
region is always fixed to be a string of
zeros like in those images just yellow
and what this seems to indicate is that
even though it doesn't take that much
more to get a conserve antibody against
the conserve region like how those two
lines are quite close because of this
first antibody response this kids broad
antibody response is quite delayed and
going back to the empirical data where
they found that broadly neutralizing
antibodies tend to arise later and they
tend to be more mutated well they could
be later because this first antibody
response dominates and then they're more
mutated because while they arose later
and maybe just because they've hung out
in the body for longer there's more
mutation this is by no means a proof but
this is a suggestion for what might
happen this that panel is actually just
to show you an artifact of the modeling
assumptions we made which is because
it's possible that by chance an antibody
mutates to be a string of zeros just by
chance without any selection pressure
you can get conserved antibodies these
purple lines emerging quite early
intersection which has never been
observed but then at the same time if
broadly neutralizing antibodies did as a
did happen that early in an individual
it's unclear if that would actually be
caught
in a clinical situation so these are
just three panels showing you the
dynamics of this model they're just
three separate simulations what I wanted
to look at was something more general
about this model really so let me just
show you what happens when I do multiple
simulations and here I instead of
seating the infection with just one
virus I take one two three five or ten
randomly selected viruses and I see
whether in the span of 60 days broad
antibody or an antibody against the
conserved region arises so this data
point is showing you what the previous
slide showed you and you can see that
it's more likely for abroad anybody to
arise if you have more viruses in your
initial infection and that's purely
because the conserved epitope only has a
selective advantage after this when you
have many different variable epitopes
that are in the population that diabetes
a selective advantage for any particular
antibody to bind to that specific
episode let me just give this rough so
this is just showing you that under the
assumptions of this model it would make
sense for a vaccine to just have a
mixture of different virus strains
to elicit that broadly neutralizing
antibody yeah we're looking into that
all right so in the last ten minutes let
me just tell you about this general
model of multi-level selection in host
pathogen systems and Jonathan already
talked about this in terms of this
trade-off I like to think about it as a
selection within host the host may not
be the same as selection between hosts
so let me just use the human papilloma
virus as an example I want to talk about
the other two sir there are two types of
HPV they're called high risk and low
risk ironically low risk is the one that
divides FASTA or is more aggressive
because what happens is when the virus
is more aggressive it sort of triggers
the immune response earlier and it
actually gets eliminated from the body
the lower the higher is
type doesn't divide as quickly as lot as
aggressive the immune response doesn't
respond to it so it actually ends up
doing a lot of damage in terms of this
picture the high-risk type is
replicating really quickly so you can
think of it as being at this small level
it's beating it's winning but somehow
because the immune system responds to it
very quickly it doesn't have time to
transmit so this is a antagonistic
multi-level selection that I'm going to
refer to something that's beneficial at
the weather the first level is not
helping a bit between hours levels and
just to give you a very simple model for
this phenomenon and this is just the
Moran model at two levels I'm going to
assume a fixed number of groups and a
fixed number of individuals per group N
and red is going to be the beneficial
type within hosts and that means that
red replicates at rate 1 plus s whereas
blue represents a trip rate 1 and what
that means is this in this group that
individual replicated and to keep the
number of individuals per group constant
I'm going to beautiful may choose
another individual in that group to die
so here the blue dyed blue groups be
treta groups in that the fraction of the
blue group determines is linearly
proportional to the rate of replication
so here this what's gonna happen if this
blue group is going to replicate and
also to keep the number of groups
constant I'm going to choose the sender
of this group to die and finally I have
two events at the two levels so I'm
ready to have a relative rate at which
group level events occur to individual
elements and that's the W so here's the
this is the model and I'm going to draw
it in this way to make it easier to
formulate mathematically the first type
of an I showed you was an individual
level event and originally I had a group
with zero blue so that's here a group
with two blue which is here and a group
with three blue which is here so this is
a bowl and urn representation of that
picture and after that first move we're
a group with two blue became a group
with two
that corresponds to a bowl moving from
two to one and you'll realize that every
type of individual level event is going
to be a nearest neighbor move here it
just moved left and in general because
red has a faster replication rate than
blue most of these moves while these
moves will have a drift towards zero
towards the left the second event I
showed you was this group replicating
completely and that group died being
removed and you can think of that as a
group with zero blue leaving the
population and a group with three blue
and during the population also good
thing about is the bowl from zero moving
to three so all group level events
correspond to occupied moves to occupied
urns and they tend to go towards the
right because blue groups are better
than Retta groups and you can also see
that individual level events are when
balls move according to individual level
events they're independent of the other
balls
but when balls both of these urns move
according to group level events they
depend on where the other Bulls in the
other notes are because they moved to
occupy those so let me just show you a
simulation of this unprocess with larger
number of arms and a larger number of
balls and you can see there's a lot of
noise but there is also some tendency to
pull balls to move that way in some
appendices it's a false move this way so
having reduced this multi level pathogen
system into Justin and model there's
actually a lot of math we can do so let
me just to introduce some notation let
each Bowl in that unprocess view denoted
by XJ and the subscript T tells you its
position at time T and we're going to
focus on the measure value process the
histogram the distribution of the bowls
at any given time and that's given by u
sub T and in for those who aren't
familiar this with this notation just
think of muse of T and n as a
distribution
I told you the transition rates and
pictures but let me just show you you
can write it down mathematically this
one plus s and this one plus odd g of n
corresponds to those two types of moves
so R sub one is individual level moves
us up to a group level moves and with
this system we can actually prove
rigorously but you can also show just by
taking a mean field approximation that
there are two limits so the first limit
as you take eminent to infinity is a
deterministic one and what that means is
that in this picture with bold and ends
this distribution the dynamics of the
distribution change deterministically
okay there was a lot of noise in this
picture but in this limit it goes to a
distribution that changes the time in a
super look and that's given by this
partial differential equation and this
term is flux that represents the
individual level events this term is a
foreseen that represents the group level
one so you have in this very
mathematical physical form the different
forces of selection acting on the
distribution and the other limit also a
feminine going to infinity but now with
the rescaling that s is Sigma over n R
is Rho over m and n over m going to
alpha you get a funny viewer limit it's
an SP de limit so you can think of this
as the drift part of the FCE so this is
like a PDE if you ignored this and then
this is the noise and this noise term is
what makes this a Fleming vo limit
because this coefficient in front of
space-time white noise is the infinite
infinite dimensional analog of right
Fischer diffusion if you guys any of you
familiar with that so let me just
briefly I have like three minutes left
three okay let me just show you what the
deterministic one it looks like so here
lambda in the deterministic limit is
just wrff let me show you the only
parameter that's important here after
you divide through by s and rescale time
is W R of s and I'm just going to call
that lambda and so the dynamics of this
PDE have different behaviors depending
on lambda so here lambda is low which
means the flux corresponding till
individual level events is stronger than
the forcing cars wanting to group level
events so you see the distribution grow
up towards sort of like a delta function
to 0 and when lambda is large the
forcing term of corresponding to the
group level events is stronger than the
flux term corresponding to individual
level events and you get something
that's more bias to what's wrong
also the fact that there's only one
parameter in this deterministic limit
tell you something about the relative
rate of replication W because the
product W R is there anything that's
important in this PDE you can sort of
say that W acts in this limit sort of
like the Selective coefficient at the
group level and indeed if you go back to
the ball and and model the simulations
and you increase W and you look at the
time to fixation of the blue type so the
types of a beneficial of the group level
the time decreases as you increase W so
that's in some sense consistent with the
group level selection being stronger and
then finally you know what does this PDE
tell us about what happens when N and M
a finite the original system well this
is the result of basically all the
demographic noise going away
this first time deterministically pushes
mass toward zero and the second term
deterministically forces mass towards
one
so when MN and a finite what this is
saying if M is finite then this term is
not as strong as its deterministic limit
so you're weakening group level
selection if M is finite or if M is love
and if n is finite and is the number of
individuals per group you're weakening
individual level selection so this is
not purely deterministic to10 and so
it's lower n lower number of lower group
sizes is going to reduce the effect of
individual level selection take it to
the extreme if you have group sizes of
two that's actually the most beneficial
situation for group advantageous traits
because I cut down my talk that's
actually where I wanted to end so there
are any questions I'd be happy to take
them you don't see a peak in the middle
but so in this picture I showed you
Landry called 1.5 mm equals 4 if lambda
equals true that it just stays like this
and the threshold is I didn't get time
to talk about this but depending on your
initial condition and its derivative at
1 the does a threshold flow ends up for
which you get either going that way
anymore
so for your problem utilizing anybody
what would when you have this freest
problem beginning where there was
probably like sort of neutralizing
antibodies showing up because there is a
constant region just essentially because
up stochasticity if you just increase
instead of doing a binary matching model
if you number of states with your model
contain what do you mean by binary
matching so I mean if you would
basically increase the probability that
you get a string of zeros by increased
in the state space I see so that would
definitely decrease this happening but
it also decreases the possibility of
have ever seen anyways I think there's
two a connected service it would just be
a yeah you could increase the number of
alphabet whether its annual straight to
and that would decreases but I think
that just means this is always going to
be a problem and probably if this
happens it's going to be some common
factor probably think he's willing you
try the anybody missives up when we do
want to see it I guess I think that this
is a really big state space in reality
right
but in reality it also takes nine years
sometimes to see these broadly
neutralising antibodies so if we make
the state thing smaller at least in the
simulation and times became through we
might be able to see the interesting
behavior
I think if we increase the state space
it would be much more realistic but it
would also require much more
computational power just see this kind
of dynamic I don't know if the quality
quality of the qualitative properties
would be although I have insight